c'est pourquoi j'y reviendrai dans un
instant nous prenons des mesures très
fortes pour augmenter massivement nos
capacités d'accueil à l'hôpital cette
promesse d' emmanuel macron en mars 2020
n'a pas vraiment été suivies d'effet pas
moins de cinq mille 700 lits
d'hospitalisation complète ont été
fermées en 2020 seul 1400 places
d'hospitalisation partiel ont été créés
en plus pour un bilan global négatif de
4300 lee c'est ce que démontrent les
chiffres d'une étude du ministère de la
santé paru mercredi en 2020 le nombre de
lits en état d'accueillir des patients
continuent de reculer -1 5% il convient
de nuancer ce chiffre car deschamps mon
dû être réorganisé pour le traitement du
corps vide mais il en reste que la
baisse constatée en 2020 correspond à
une véritable tendance trois mille
quatre cents lits d'hospitalisation
complète avait déjà disparu en 2019 et
4000 en 2018 en 2020
2983 structures hospitalières offre des
capacités d'accueil en hospitalisation
complète de 387 1000 lits et de 80000
places en hospitalisation partielle et
voilà ce que répercutent l'étude depuis
2013 ce sont en effet 27 mille lits
d'hospitalisation complète qui ont ainsi
été fermées soit une baisse de 6 5% à 7
ans et l'étude relève que le nombre de
sites géographiques répertoriés continue
de diminuer traduire les hôpitaux de
proximité sont supprimés au grand dam
des habitants de province qui doivent
rouler des dizaines de kilomètres pour
pouvoir se faire soigner soixante dix
huit hôpitaux publics ont ainsi fermé
leurs portes depuis 2013 fort
logiquement ces temps de pandémie à
rebours de cette tendance on observe une
augmentation des lits affectés au
traitement du coït 19 le nombre de lits
en soins critiques a augmenté de 3,6
pour cent entre fin 2019 et fin 2020
avec 786 lits de réanimation
supplémentaires mais comment pourrait-il
en être autrement alors du virus moins
de lits moins d'hôpitaux en conclusion
comment l'étude interpréter ces chiffres
se replie poursuit une tendance observée
depuis plusieurs années qui reflète la
volonté de réorganiser l'offre dans un
contexte de virage ambulatoire mais
aussi de contraintes de personnel ne
permettant pas de maintenir les lie donc
dans un mouvement inverse aux pertes de
lits d'hospitalisation complète l'étude
relève une augmentation des places en
hospitalisation à domicile
plus 10,8 pour cent en 2020 après +6 2%
en 2019 mais depuis 2013 seuls huit
mille deux cents de ces places ont été
créées à mettre en perspective avec les
vingt-sept milly perdu sur ce graphique
la courbe des pertes et des guerres de
licence ce qu'on pensait mais c'est
juste en raison d'une différence
d'échelle avec une échelle similaire
pour les deux courbes voilà le travail
quant aux contraintes liées au personnel
citées par l'étude le syndicaliste de
force ouvrière gilles gadier nous donne
son avis des aides soignantes des
infirmiers il n'y en a pas suffisamment
un nombre formé sur le marché du travail
à l'heure actuelle est d'ailleurs bon
nombre d'établissements nous dise si on
souhaitait même les recruter on ne les
aurait pas parce qu'ils ont pas présent
donc il faut renforcer à la fois en
termes de formation le nombre les
capacités des instituts de formation en
soins infirmiers et en personnel et de
soignants pour pourvoir peut être
amélioré la situation en tout cas la
fermeture massive de lits ulcère les
soignants qui en réclame de nouveau l
embauche du personnel correspondant
olivier vers ans en novembre 2020 a
confirmé la promesse du président et
affirmé vouloir ouvrir des lits à
l'hôpital nous ferons donc les comptes
en 2021 alors que des restructurations
et fermetures continuent à s'enchaîner